Is Mist Cutter Hydra a draw spell? Now,
I know you're probably asking, "Is this
snail guy off his goddamn rocker?" And
don't worry, I'm not going to try to
convince you that a French vanilla
beater is a draw spell. But it does kind
of accomplish some of the same tasks.
And running cards that can soak up more
of your mana might actually allow you to
run less draw. Think about it. If I cast
a Night Whisper to draw into two beaters
and then play both of them, what was the
difference between that and a single
X-ost creature that I simply poured all
my mana into instead? This sort of
observation is most relevant for what's
sometimes called battle cruiser decks.
Lategame mid-range decks that often run
decent amounts of ramp with the goal of
outscaling opponents. In these decks,
the goal is to obtain a lot of mana and
then spend all of that mana. And draw is
just one way of spending mana. My rata
air ddh deck has a fairly narrow draw
suite containing just 10 cards, most of
which accomplish other tasks for the
deck as well. But this amount is more
than enough because the average non-land
mana value is 5.33. Drawing three cards
is usually drawing more than 10 mana
worth of spells.